in LA there you've got criterion Meaghan
now yes you need to have the prefer some
tea well we keep inviting them over
anyone who follows my Instagram knows
that my wife and I keep inviting them
over and they haven't taken us up on our
invitation just yet but I feel like if I
keep inviting them and keep opposing you
know over-the-top meals and things that
one of these days I'm gonna get a knock
on the door and Harry and Megan are
gonna actually show up so how are you
guys cuz I'm from like cooking and
baking you know how's it going are you
doing homeschooling with the kids how's
all of that happening sure my fourth
grader it's pretty it's pretty easy
because all his schoolwork is pretty
easy but my seventh grader her stuff is
getting pretty complicated right she's
in it she's doing calculus and she's
doing stuff like that so it's um yeah
it's it's definitely a trip down memory
lane case is over when you going to
Seattle
[Music]
not tonight
something the core too is season 4 of
privatize your friend Keshia chante
George us for a few episodes this last
season that's gonna be coming soon and
she was fantastic she is a sweetheart as
you as you know so we had a lot of fun
this year and so hopefully people will
get to watch the the episodes of shots
here very soon I think I come back it's
been a couple years since I had my my
walk on with my big hair we would love
to have you anytime you you were welcome
on our show anytime you know that here's
a random one for you if you could be in
quarantine when any of the nine oh two
one oh characters who would you want to
be in quarantine with and who would you
not want to be important to whoa man I
wouldn't want to be in quarantine with
Donna Martin because she is way too high
maintenance and I would want to be in
quarantine with Steve Sanders man
because Steve Sanders is just fun yes
fun good life
[Music]